foreign
[Music]
this is a truth which holds good for
everything that lives and knows though
man alone can bring it into reflective
and Abstract consciousness
this is how Arthur schopenhauer
introduces us to his most celebrated
work the world as will and
representation such a potent way to
introduce your audience to your inner
World requires quite some audacity and
schopenhauer showcased a considerate
amount of it throughout his life he was
the philosopher that preceded Nietzsche
and succeeded her account these three
philosophy Moguls created a Continuum of
critical thinking and life-defining
Concepts that influenced the Western
thought like few schopenhauer was a man
of great depth who tried to understand
the maladies of The Human Condition and
propose pragmatic ways to deal with it
through his writings I discovered
Notions that not only re-engineer the
ways we think about ourselves and our
relationship with reality but also
transcend the way with you the very
fabric of reality
foreign
schopenhauer's work was dense and his
language assertive he was a pessimist
but also a pragmatist he detested the
simplistic arguments and wanted to get
the gist of things most of his ideas
emerged from a strong desire to live a
life that was within his scope of
understanding but also faced the truth
about reality regardless of how harsh
this may be the main concept developed
by schopenhauer is that of the will to
live the will to live a village
schopenhauer calls it is the expression
of the desire of all nature to pursue
and propagate life without will there
can be no life but it is also through
wheel that most of Mankind's misery and
suffering is manifested we as humans are
consumed by our drives drives such as
sexual desires pursuit of pleasure
needful interaction Will To Power the
appreciation of Aesthetics and much more
they're all integral constituents of the
way we operate and they all fall under
the umbrella of the will to live life
isn't just an abstract concept for us it
is an experience manifested through a
plethora of wheels that are intertwined
in an attempt to form an ensemble that
justifies the reasoning behind our
existence but this multiplicity of
individual Wills isn't limited solely to
the human Dimension it can be found in
the whole of nature in ways we cannot
comprehend due to our limited perception
this is what schopenhauer calls the
wheel with capital W and this limited
the perception according to schopenhauer
is the source of our misery and
suffering the world is apprehensible
only through examination and
introspection and through the
Transcendence of egoism that each human
is endowed with he goes the enemy an
enemy that can be confronted only
through self-awareness empathy and
knowledge the curse that has befall in
our species is that we cannot really
free ourselves from the will the will
can be released or negated but it can't
change within this landscape we ought to
attempt to operate in the most effective
way possible it sounds like an arduous
challenge it feels like a groping and
fumbling in the dark but schopenhauer
believes that the denial of the will to
live might be the only way to Salvation
from suffering this pessimistic Outlook
towards life is observed all over his
narrative and it was because of this
stone that many refer to him as the
philosopher of pessimism
in the absurdity of reality has always
been the main area of interest for most
western philosophers schopenhauer in his
attempt to create meaning out of this
absurdity adopted a very pessimistic
rhetoric take for example the following
passage from the world as well and
representation and to this world and to
this scene of tormented and agonized
beings who only continue to Exist by
devouring each other in which therefore
every ravenous Beast is the living grave
of thousands of others and itself
maintenance is a chain of painful deaths
and in which the capacity for feeling
pain increases with knowledge and
therefore reaches its highest degree in
man a degree which is the higher the
more intelligent the man is to this
world it has been sought to apply the
system of optimism and demonstrate to us
that it is the best of all possible
Worlds the absurdity thing is glaring it
is self-evident that his inner world is
tormented due to the absurdity that is
prevalent all over our existence however
he doesn't give up he understands that
there is an escape even if this can be
found on a metaphysical level not merely
that the world exists but still more
than it is such a miserable and
Melancholy world is the tormenting a
problem of metaphysics here he's
mentioning the world of metaphysics by
realizing that there needs to be another
dimension to our existence one we will
never experience if we keep recycling
the same thinking motifs the life of
every individual viewed as a whole and
in general and when only its most
significant features are emphasized is
really a tragedy but gone through in
detail it has the character of a comedy
sarcasm is also a weapon he uses from
time to time in order to alleviate the
significance of the tragedy of The Human
Condition through self-awareness we come
to understand that our creator has
either a very artistic taste or that he
she eat or they are testing us when we
realize how tragic that is we end up
thinking that it could all be a travesty
of some sort having to deal with this
level of absurdity makes you either
angry or you laugh at it for if anything
in the world is desirable so desirable
that even the dull and uneducated heard
in its more reflective moments would
value it more than silver and gold it is
that a ray of light should fall on the
obscurity of our existence and that we
should obtain some information about
this enigmatical life of ours in which
nothing is clear except it's misery and
vanity eventually he ends up adopting a
more pragmatic stance lamenting can only
get one so far and after we get over our
anger we need to face the truth and deal
with it schopenhauer emphasizes that in
the face of a world filled with endless
Strife our only Escape is a universal
moral awareness that will allow us to
achieve a more balanced Frame of Mind by
merging Christian ideas and Indian
wisdom he attempts to lay out some major
principles of moral awareness that can
lead the humanity to a more balanced
State principles such as the repudiation
of violence altogether the idea that one
should treat others as one treats
oneself the Transcendence of egoism the
fight against suffering in the world and
the perennial cultivation of compassion
as an absolute humanitarian Doctrine
after tasting the truth of human nature
from a moral standpoint schopenhauer
realizes that there are only two paths
that can help one deal with this
conundrum Aesthetics and asceticism
Aesthetics is presented as the antidote
to the agginess of suffering it is
through aesthetic perception that the
Transcendence of ego can manifest itself
for with Aesthetics we can evaluate an
idea beyond our Earthly interpretation
of reality orienting Consciousness
towards states of mind that are less
individuated and more Cosmic has always
inspired great thinkers hence the strong
Affinity towards Eastern philosophies
only through the pure contemplation
which becomes absorbed entirely in the
object are the ideas comprehended and
the nature of Genius consists precisely
in the preeminent ability for such
contemplation this demands a complete
forgetting of our own person we can
temporarily emancipate ourselves from
what the will dictates through an
aesthetic experience on the occurrence
of an aesthetic appreciation the will
thereby vanishes entirely from
consciousness
asceticism on the other hand arises as
the more secure attitude since according
to schopenhauer aesthetic perception due
to its transient nature is most of the
time short-lived asceticism can result
in the denial towards our way to live
thus allowing us to fight against the
suffering that the will attempts to
impose Upon Us by the expression
asceticism which I have already used so
often I understand in the not aware
sense this deliberate breaking of the
will by refusing the agreeable and
looking for the disagreeable he
voluntarily chosen way of life of
penance and self-tastisement for the
constant mortification of the will the
issue usually highlighted as a
contradiction in this way of thinking is
that the suffering that asceticism tries
to us wage paradoxically leads to
different types of suffering like
isolation anxiety anti-social Behavior
sexual operation and so on regardless of
how asceticism is portrayed or exercised
schopenhauer truly believes that the
ascetic struggle is the ultimate
struggle against the will and this
acting itself can give us a modicum of
what self-transcendence might actually
feel like many prominent philosophical
figures criticized schopenhauer's work
and claimed that there are numerous
contradictions in his philosophy this is
inevitable when one possesses such a
genius in the art of abstract reasoning
the world is full of contradictions and
we should all just embrace the reality
of this schopenhauer with his Works has
rightfully earned a place in the
pantheon of philosophers across space
and time in my first introduction to him
he made me a pessimist but then he
helped me enjoy life his words can be
mesmerizing and can alleviate the pain
of existence for most of Us in so far as
we open our hearts and our minds to them
[Music]